so hello everybody i am sitting here
with paul kingsnorth
paul king north is a writer uh from the
uk he has written several novels also
several
other other books and uh he's been kind
of put on my horizon by several people
have been
telling me that you need to i need to
pay attention to him uh rodriguez and
then several priests actually and
many artists that are around me and so
i'm actually reading one of his novels
now the novel beast
but i thought it would be a good
opportunity for you to meet him and to
talk a little bit about
his journey and his vision of where we
are in the world and
how we can be how we can play a positive
role in where the world is going
this is jonathan pedro welcome to the
symbolic world
and so paul thank you for coming i
really appreciate you giving me the time
here
well thanks for inviting me on it's
great to meet you yeah wonderful
so i'm right now i'm starting your novel
i have to admit that i i'm not very far
into it so i'm not
completely aware i've read a little bit
a few of your articles and a bit of your
um
of your vision of of how artists can
participate in this so maybe you can
tell us a little bit about
your own journey in terms of uh
how you see how you've seen the world
and what that's where that's brought you
and then we can talk about some vision
of the future let's say
yeah sure i mean it's um yes it's kind
of strange and winding journey like for
a lot of us i imagine
i mean i've uh i've been a writer for
about 25 years now in various forms
always wanted to be one but i was also
um
i was also an environmental activist for
a long time and and that came um
that really developed out of a what i
can i can't really only describe it as a
spiritual connection to nature i know
that sounds terribly vague but i've
always had a sort of
religious or sense of religious or
spiritual sensibility in terms of
connection with places
and love of the natural world i had that
since i was a child
and that sort of turned itself into
environmental activism when i was a
student
i spent a lot of time campaigning to
protect forests and
campaigning to protect landscapes and a
lot of direct action a lot of political
activism climate change and all the rest
of it
um and the more you look into that the
more you start to realize that there's a
deep disconnection between people and
places
between people and nature and that
actually
that that's to me a spiritual concern as
much as anything else
and that was one of the things that led
me in the end to sort of i suppose
part ways with the mainstream green
movement which is highly technocratic
very political um very much sees
the environmental crisis globally as a
sort of technical problem
or a political problem to be solved with
machinery or carbon counting or
political agreements whereas to me it's
a problem of relationship
um a real major global and particularly
western problem with the way that we're
living in terms of the rest of
nature or creation however you want to
put it um and
certainly in recent years we're starting
to see a big cultural disintegration in
the west we're starting to see
um major ecological disintegration
everywhere
in terms of climate change and mass
extinction and all sorts of other
horrors that we hear about all the time
and the more i look at this the more
i've been putting it all together in my
writing in fiction and non-fiction
the more i've seen it as a as a kind of
interlinked cultural and ecological
crisis which is
ultimately a root i think a spiritual
crisis it's about us being completely
out of relationship with
with life actually with the rest of
human life the way that we live with
each other but also
the the non-human life and that that's
just that's a spiritual question that's
about how we're living with
with creation with each other so really
i've been on a journey from
activism to kind of post-activism i
suppose if you like
and now now a kind of very openly uh
i suppose religious or spiritual aspect
to that where i think
okay what's what's the reason what's the
big picture here what's really going on
what's the brokenness at the heart of
this because something is very broken
and i think we can all feel that and and
particularly since 2020
it's just been kind of accelerating at
light speed i think we can all feel
something really big is going on
and it isn't nice and we don't quite
know how to put it down
but think all sorts of things are
falling apart and that's a difficult
thing to live through but it's also
the way i try to look at it is it's also
the beginning of something else
you know something else is coming along
here and
what is it is the question that i
suppose interests me now yeah
one of the things that has been
interesting to me watching the
environmental
question has been how the discourse has
has often been radicalized in the sense
that
the i always have this sense that the
modern world is really a deincarnation
you know that christianity it's as if
christianity had a
a kind of synthetic worldview let's say
that became quite strong in the middle
ages and then
in the renaissance and enlightenment
things started to split and we didn't
see the fruits of that at first but now
we're really seeing the the fruits and
uh you know in i've always actually had
a tenuous relationship with the
environmental
kind of activism because what i saw in
it was a
something of an extreme kind of coming
out and this
the the idea even the idea of like
nature as a value in itself like the
idea of
nature the idea of the wild you could
say uh because there's something of the
place that you talk about
which which which brings human
consciousness to the fore
right the idea of a place in the sense
that we recognize this as a
having respect or reverence for a place
means that it
it's like a the garden is the best image
of that where there is a human element
in the sense of a human recognition of a
boundary
and then this this like natural
interaction within the
the space whereas what i've noticed in
the um
a lot of the environmental rhetoric is
this kind of fetishization of the
of the wild let's say and a hatred
almost of almost an anti-human
quality in it i don't think it's there
everywhere maybe it's there mostly in
those that
make the most noise and so we kind of
hear it more um and so because of that
i've been i've always been tenuous about
it i
i appreciate the desire because i see
the insanity of
of of western culture like i can notice
the insanity of uh
consumerism and the and this complete uh
treating the world like heidegger talked
about right there the idea of the world
as the standing reserve is just this
stuff that we can use to
to further our own agenda um and so and
so i i'm curious about your vision of
that because i
i haven't seen at least me i haven't
seen a lot of people that are able to
kind of find that
balance in the cosmological sense almost
like in a in a
symbolic sense well it's interesting
isn't it i mean the
the i mean look i wrote a manifesto
called uncivilization right so i'm i've
been quite
quite deep in this but look i mean the
people
are in in the radical green movement
especially people are
desperate to protect the wild because
we're destroying it so fast so if you
look at it in terms of balance there's
always a balance between
the wild world which is the world that
basically isn't under the control
or domination of humans mainly modern
humans
and and human civilization now i tend to
think that in a traditional society
in a pre-modern society in other words
there's a reasonable balance between the
human and the non-human
world and you don't have a kind of
environmental conversation
because you don't need one because
you're not destroying everything you're
in some reasonable balance with it you
know you don't have to romanticize
nature
but you don't demonize it either and you
don't just treat it as a resource i mean
i live in rural ireland
there's a great long tradition of of
folk culture here just as there is in
england where i come from
which has a weary respect for nature and
which treats it well and you have to do
that because it's a living web
what we've done and i think i don't
think this is a problem of so of western
culture so much as it's about modernity
because it's started here but it's
global now um
where we have basically desold
everything that isn't human
right and increasingly desold other
humans as well but we treat the world as
a resource
because we treat um we treat the whole
of life as a machine
and we treat most of non-human life and
indeed much human life as a kind of
resource to be fed into that machine and
turned into profit
at the other side so that's a question
of that's
as i say this is a spiritual matter
because it's question of
respect for creation which includes
humans
um and if you don't if you don't respect
that if you create a giant machine that
eats everything effectively and destroys
destroys everything and tries to turn it
into plastic junk that we don't even
need
then you're going to get a huge reaction
in in terms of people who want to defend
the wild from
from humans and what happens a lot is
that people get human civilization the
worst aspects of modernity
confused with human beings and they say
humans are the problem humans aren't the
problem
but the way that modern humans are
living is the problem
and that's that's a problem in any
number of ways not just in terms of
i mean i see the the destruction of the
natural world the wild world is as a
symptom
of of the bigger crisis and and that the
sort of
disintegration of aspects of our culture
at the moment is a symptom of the same
crisis i think
i mean you mentioned the garden i think
it's very interesting that i think a lot
about the
the notion of eden and the fall um you
know the the sort of primal story of
christianity is that
we begin in communion in a garden with
everything else that's alive and with
god
who's so close to us that we can see him
walking around
okay and and there we are everything is
there all life is there
and we chose to leave that because we
chose power
and knowledge and and desire if you like
individual self-will over communion
so we've spent the whole of history
trying to get back again you know or
attempting to rebuild our own garden
here on earth which is effectively
the point we're coming to now after so
many centuries of trying to
to build our own godless world with us
at the center of it
this is what we've come to and and the
destruction of you know the fact that
you can change the climate of a whole
planet
by playing god um to me that's a
spiritual matter you know
so the question is then not you know
what technology should we use instead of
this one the question is
so what what happened that's that's the
result of eating the apple if you like
so what do we do now
what do we do now that's a spiritual
matter that's a that's got to have a
spiritual answer to it
there's an interesting image because you
can see if you look at the story of the
fall you can notice
how technology is an answer to the fall
and it's
it comes from kane's lineage so kane is
the first one to build a city
and then you can see this kind of
pendulum swing between
what you could call the wild and
civilization the biggest example is of
course the flood
which is which is let's say this coming
in of the wild to take revenge let's say
on on
on excess of order and then right away
after the flood what is the first thing
they want to do is they want to build a
tower
they build a tower so it's like if there
ever a flood comes again you know we'll
be safe
and so you see this kind of pendulum
moving back and forth between these two
extremes
and the the powerful imagery of the new
jerusalem
is actually a balance that people
wouldn't think that that's how the
balance should be but it's a it's a
powerful balance because
in the center of the city is the tree
and the water of life
and then on the margin is the the wall
of the city
and so we tend to think the opposite we
tend to think that it's like the city in
the center
and then the trees in the wild on the
outside but the image that is brought
about
in the new jerusalem is rather of this
this kind of pristine reality in the
center
and then the the wall is there to kind
of protect almost
protect that that uh pristine reality
rather than
rather than the opposite let's say um
and but it's it's pristine but it's also
more of a garden than it is just of the
let's say of the wild the way that we
understand it
because in the in the last image it also
says that the that there's no ocean
which is actually a crazy image that
that image is hard to totally understand
when it says in revelation that
there's no ocean left you're thinking
there's no ocean no chaos at all like i
don't totally get it
uh but but that's the final images of
this let's say
there's flowing water but not uh not
this kind of chaotic
water let's say as i don't know if you
ever if you ever
noticed that this this this interesting
final image of how the garden and the
city come together in the no
no i hadn't thought of that actually no
but i mean i think yeah the tower of
babel is another one of those great
stories i puzzled over for ages i
thought this is very strange stories of
what's going on here but yeah it's
this is everyone gets together and says
you know if we build this high enough
we'll we'll get up we'll get back to god
where we should be
and yeah and it's also the one thing
that's kind of implicit in the story is
that it's getting back to god but it's
also
avoiding the flood because they just
came out of a flood and so they're
saying
if we build up high enough you know
we'll reach the god and then we'll also
be safe
if there are these these waters because
there's a tradition that says
that the garden of eden was never like
san fran the syrian
there's a tradition that talked about
how the garden of eden uh was never
flooded and that the
the water of the flood came up to the
gates of the garden and never entered
um so this image of this reality which
is above the chaos and kind of holds
and the man says no i'm going to build
that like i'm going to build a mountain
you know i'm going to build a
a thing that's going to avoid any
problem and like right now if you
understand like when we look at the
control measures of
of of coba that are being set into place
you get a sense that there's something
of that where it's
where people think that they're going to
create a world where there's no danger
where there's no
risk this is the machine isn't it surely
right this is this is the fall this is
what you do when you eat the apple right
you say
i'm not going to trust god which is the
same thing as trusting
nature actually because that's the
creation right i'm not going to trust
god i'm not going to be in the garden
i'm not going to live
within the natural law i'm going to take
control of everything and i'm going to
build a world which is better what that
means
is a world that's better for people okay
so it doesn't matter if we kill
everything else to do that
and it doesn't matter if we end up
actually putting ourselves into a kind
of slave state
where we have no freedom either because
at least we're in control so it's this
desperate grasping for too much
order and then then the pendulum swings
and then comes the chaos which is the
climate change which is the extinction
which is the cultural disintegration
because that's what happens if you try
power without wisdom yeah that's i just
you know this is
this constant i'm finding you know it's
interesting to me when i look at the new
testament when i look at the gospels and
i think
the ultimate image of jerusalem there is
an image of murderous power
right i mean over the over civilization
of jerusalem it's when jesus goes to
jerusalem that he's tortured and
brutalized and killed
most of the time he's wandering around
in small cities he's hanging around by
the lake cooking fish on the floor
he's um you know he's he's in the small
towns he's in the villages he's going
barefoot
it's when he goes to the city and tries
to take the message to the heart of
empire
that he ends up crucified that's what
the power does you know it's like the
city as an
image of this great controlling kind of
moloch this
this babylon if you like there's always
a balance and if the
if it gets out of balance you know we
talk about chaos in order if the balance
gets out
this is what you do and it seems to me
that modernity takes
obviously takes god out of the picture
and that means it takes humility out of
the picture and it takes
if you remove obviously anything that's
above you then you become the center of
the picture
so humans are at the center of the
modern story so why not just make the
world in our image and we know where
this ends up this ends up in silicon
valley
this ends up in transhumanism this ends
up with let's upload our minds and live
forever
and let's re let's remake everything in
the world from the nano level downwards
so that it suits modern human beings
which is the kind of the project at the
moment
and yeah absolutely with kovid has kind
of accelerated this race
towards great controlling machine and
it's uh it is like um
very much like the temptation of uh of
the snake you know it's very much like
the devil's offer it's like well you can
look you get all this power but
obviously you lose all of your freedom
you know and you destroy the and the
rest of nature but never mind because at
least you can behave like gods
yeah and there's there's the images that
you brought about of jerusalem is so
powerful because we know that jerusalem
also got destroyed and some one of the
warnings that christ is telling them and
they don't know but they they don't
understand but he's telling them like
it's coming there's something coming you
don't
see it but there's a there's something
on the horizon it's almost like
there's a play on the story of jonah in
christ's
story because jonah goes to the city
warns the city and they repent
and he says even that the animals repent
which is really fascinating
and so he says that they repent and then
god preserves the city
uh whereas christ is basically telling
them you need to repent they don't and
then jerusalem is uh
is actually destroyed yeah god is not
mocked
yeah actions have consequences you know
and so tell me a little bit because i i
know that your journey
ultimately did lead you to to to
christianity to orthodoxy
and so i'm curious to know a little bit
about your process about how you
because for a lot of although i although
i think that you sense and i
sense that this is a move that's
happening like there's a there's an
interesting
zeitgeist right now there's a there's a
there's a capacity of people to move
towards christianity and to understand
it that maybe wasn't there
even 20 years ago uh but i'd like you
maybe to hear kind of in your words how
this how
this led how you were led to this yeah
well
i was led to it because i didn't want to
go there um at all i did not want to be
a christian i'd point this out
i didn't like christianity and i didn't
like christians and i didn't want to be
a christian
so you know god's got a sense of humor
he definitely has got a sense of humor i
mean look i was a kind of eco pagan
right when you're when you're an
environmentalist
you know you're in love with nature and
and you want to
if you if you realize this is a
spiritual matter and so many people do
um you end up wanting some sort of
container for that and so people look
for that
but there isn't one um in the modern
world i mean you know there are all
sorts of old nature religions around but
we haven't got them anymore in the west
there's no way of connecting with the
divine through nature in any serious way
so you try all sorts of things and i've
tried all sorts of things i mean i was
actually a zen buddhist for a while
that's a slightly different
uh different tact but i started about
ten years ago looking for a path and i
practiced zen
and zen zen is a very good path it's a
very disciplined serious old past but
but there was something missing from it
which turned out to be god which is what
i was looking for
and then i was into yeah i was exploring
all sorts of mythical parts over as a
wiccan for a while
which was interesting um and quite fun
but again you have a sense that this is
a modern thing that's been constructed
out of old bits some of which work and
some of which don't but it isn't there's
no theology to it there's no seriousness
to it there's something
isn't there and and this is you know the
state of the modern world is i think
where so many
orthodox people especially get into
reading
father seraphim rose you know because
he's like the patron saint of lost
western people
who go through everything before they
find christianity i mean he was
he was doing everything he was studying
chinese he was practicing
every faith because this is what we do
in the west because we haven't we feel
we have nowhere to go
and the reason for that is that the
western church for so long was tied up
with power
it was tied up with the institutions
that actually were crushing people and
were destroying the earth
and there's the old christian story
about dominating and subduing earth
which everybody believes is what the
faith is about
and so for rightly or wrongly everybody
has a very
negative um attitude to christianity and
especially established christianity
um because it seems to be tied up with
the system that's crushing everything
you know it's tied up with the
civilization that everyone in the west
has been rebelling against since at
least the 1960s
and so you don't look there and you know
i didn't look there i thought well
obviously the christianity's got nothing
for me because that's
i went to enough assemblies at school
where i had to listen to vicars
lecturing me about the gospels and had
no idea what they were talking about
and it's just um so i didn't expect to
be a christian but i had i mean
i had a number of things happen to me
over the last 18 months i had
dreams i had visions i had weird things
weird stuff happening i mean i was
i was literally dragged you know this is
jesus is quite good at this isn't it he
turns up and
drags you in he shepherds you in he says
look
come on wake up mate get a grip this is
where you're supposed to be going
so i was sort of a lot of things
happened to me i
suddenly had christians coming at me
left right and center emailing me and
talking to me about my books and
for no reason at all and it was just
like in the end i couldn't ignore it
and i thought this must be real because
i don't want it to happen
so you know i started exploring it
talking to people and
praying and learning what it was all
about and looking for a church and the
more i read
about christianity especially mystical
christianity but also especially about
eastern christianity the more i thought
this isn't the story i thought it was
you know i thought christianity was a
bunch of moral lessons
i thought it was a bunch of things you
were supposed to do so that you went to
heaven instead of hell
and you had to be good and do certain
things and i thought why would i need a
guy from 2000 years ago to tell me that
and i don't believe it anyway but the
more i realized what was actually going
on the more i realized that this is a
mystical path it's a path to god
um it's a path of stripping back and
renunciation and the more i
found orthodoxy i had a couple of
friends who turned out to be orthodox
christians which i hadn't even really
known before
and then i started reading the desert
fathers and i started reading the
the you know the the philicalia and i
thought wow this is really this is
powerful stuff this beats
anything that the buddhists have got to
offer you know or at least it's actually
very similar in some ways in terms of
the depth of
of the mystery and i thought yeah this
this
church thing that i thought i knew about
is not what
not what i thought it was and here's a
powerful path and then of course you
start reading the gospels and you think
that
there is i can't think of anything
that's more radical actually than the
teaching of christ
and you know once you start to separate
that out from many hideous things people
have done with it over the centuries you
think well this is
this is just as relevant as it ever was
and we're completely failing to do this
this is radical humility and if we had
practiced this
um we wouldn't be in this situation you
know we wouldn't be here
so the sort of um and then i was
i was reading the irish philosopher john
moriarty he's a very interesting man who
kind of combined his love of the irish
landscape and myth with his christianity
he rejected christianity as well he ran
off to canada actually he became an
academic
um and then came back home and i was
reading his autobiography and he has a
line in there and he says the story of
christianity is the story in a
story of man's rebellion against god and
i thought wow i'd never seen it like
that
and it kind of all clicked into place
when i read that i thought that's
exactly what this is isn't it we're
rebelling against god
we've put ourselves at the center of the
picture we've eaten the whole
world and now we're eating ourselves
because we're still in that rebellion so
what would
trying to get back to god look like and
when you realize that actually what
christ is teaching you is the way back
you know but you do have to carry across
so
it's not much fun it's not it's not an
easy it's not an easy path that you can
you know add to your consumer package
but i thought this yeah this is um
this is real and then i thought what am
i going to do with that information
so here i am yeah yeah but i think
you're i think your
your path is really reflecting so many
of us let's say that
found uh traditional christianity
ancient christianity
uh you know reading it's actually
there's actually it's actually a
positive thing
right now in the sense that with the new
atheists and with kind of
uh really um let's say superficial uh
superficial western christianity there's
a surprise
element that is possible it's like if
you read saint gregor vanessa if like
you said you read the philo kalia
people don't expect that they they
they've never heard about any of this
and so it's almost like uh
like you know open up the curtain at the
end and just revealing this mystery
that people didn't think was there so it
there's something exciting about
about that as well one of the things
that i've been
working on with a lot of people and i i
think you might find this interesting is
also going really going back into the
the legendary
aspects of christianity and just going
you know not
avoiding anything you know you were
talking about in ireland and
you know people who were able to unite
the ancient irish thinking and kind of
this mythical thinking with christianity
and i think that this is something that
is really it's worth our time and our
effort because it's one of the solutions
it's one of the things that's going to
re-enchant the world there's a reason
why people love
star wars and tolkien and harry potter
and all of these
all of these things is because they're
finding something in there which is
really true and
which is really invigorating and and
full of gives gives a sense of life and
christianity had
so much of that and it's it was kind of
stripped away by rationalists and
modernists
to a point where christianity itself was
stripped away um and rediscovering these
ancient stories
you know also even though like the whole
a medieval synthesis of uh
the trojan trojan legend with
christianity and alexander the great
with christianity and
this kind of ambiguous uh universal
story that
that that was flexible it wasn't uh it
wasn't like a system but it was this
flexible uh
web of references that could that could
be drawn out
and brought up and we could make
participate in our story let's say
um yeah i mean i think it's um what's so
interesting about your work is that
you're trying to find the symbolic
pattern
you know the picture of reality that
christianity is actually teaching us
which is not something i ever thought
about i didn't think christianity had
that like i said i thought it was just a
list of moral rules
you know over the last 10 years i've
been reading a lot of mythology i have
friends who are mythologists i work with
i work with myth quite a lot and it's so
obviously clear that humans need a
mythic picture of the world we have a
mythic mind
we need to see these patterns in reality
and
if you know christianity is either true
or it isn't and if it is
then it should be able to take that
picture for us and that picture should
be able to
interweave into our landscape and into
every area of our lives it's not
it's you know if christianity is a thing
which is imposed from somewhere on you
then it's a tyranny and it isn't real
and it has behaved like that sometimes
but actually at the root of it that's
not what it is and it can you know it's
so fascinating in ireland
almost every few miles in ireland there
will still be a holy well
and the holy well will have a statue of
mary over it it's never very very few
statues of christ actually it's usually
mary it's a feminine presence in this
water
there's still a great holy mountain
patrick that people do a pilgrimage up
to every year
um it's it's very much christianity here
has been in the landscape for so long
you know for a
thousand years or more and it still is
actually even though
much of the country is kind of walking
away from from the church
it's still somehow mystically in the
place
you know that's how it should be there's
a pattern of as i say there's a pattern
of reality
which ought to be able to link us back
to
the the kind of the big symbolic world
but also the ground under our feet as
well
that there's a way there's a way in
which christianity kind of seeped in so
deep in terms of
a world view for a while uh that people
took it maybe
for granted and thought as they were
starting to strip away its elements
you know thought that the world would
still that that the compass would still
remain straight even if we started to
strip that away and then as it gets
stripped away suddenly things start to
get
shaky and fragile and we start to notice
how things are falling apart
yeah and i think that's exactly where we
are in the west at the moment i think
this is the final crumbling of
christendom
yeah because a culture can't survive
without the divine at its center it's
not possible
whether it's christian or otherwise if
you have not got a divine center to your
culture
you're going to collapse into nihilism
which i think is what we're doing
i don't know if you have this in canada
we had this phenomena in britain for a
while called
atheist churches do you have it yeah i
mean it's i find them very funny
um but you know it's it's just it's just
it's telling that people still
need that structure they need a symbolic
structure which is created to take them
to god they just take god out
yeah they still go you know because
people can't actually
manage we can't manage without some
sense of
of of that great symbol of god at the
center of things
yeah the funnier ones are like these
kind of uh factus jedi orders and also
there's a u.s called uh harry potter and
the sacred text
where people will like gather in these
churches and they'll read harry potter
almost liturgically
um and then have these come like listen
i haven't heard that right
i mean cosplay is a great example of how
much people need religion it's
this desire to be in a story and to
participate and to
to have a mythical structure um but
there's something like this is
maybe what i'm seeing is that there's a
mystery in
even in the death of christianity almost
as if
it was something that was meant to
happen you know christ seemed to have
pointed
us to that and prepared us for that um
and it's almost as if just as
christ dying planted a sea that cosmic
seed that would
would grow into what it would go into
christendom it's almost as if
christianity dying is doing something
similar because
as christianity is dying there's this
distance which is created
and all of a sudden we can see the
christian story appear in places we
couldn't see it before
you know uh you know i kind of joke
about every single hollywood movie it's
basically
has a all these hollywood action movies
has a resurrection scene you need a
resurrection team
or else you're not going to make you
know uh more than 100 million with your
movie
and so it's but that's a that's a it's
like it's a christian story or even the
idea of self-sacrifice all of a sudden
we thought self-sacrifice was an obvious
trope but it's not look at look at
ancient greek myth you don't bit
you barely find that that trope there's
a maybe little little hints of it but
it's not a major
story whereas the notion that the hero
sacrifices himself for others
is a christian's story um and so as
christianity retreats we can see it
you can see it there and we can see how
it's actually going to become
more fragile as we as we retreat from
that
yeah i think david bentley heart said
something about that one of his pieces
that i read recently that
you know as christendom dies back you
can see christ more clearly
which i think is a good way of putting
it because you know also a lot of
christendom did not actually represent
christ at all
you know a lot of it actually became so
tied up with power that it became a
culture
um which wasn't necessarily following
the teachings of christ at all so
once that's gone um we can we can stand
up and go okay
well yeah now we can see what the
teachings are so
we can decide if we want to follow them
or not and we can also see that we can
also see the story more clearly perhaps
when it doesn't
well yeah like you say when we've lost
it when we've lost the structures that
were built around that story
however imperfectly we all
we can see the story but we can also
start to feel very lost
having lost it it might be a reason why
so many people are suddenly
including me finding themselves brought
into christianity not no not for
cultural reasons it's not
it's not a political decision or
anything like that it's but something's
something's calling something's going on
because it isn't possible
it isn't possible to live for very long
without
without that sacred heart and the co the
heart of your culture and that you and
at the heart of you as well it's not
you know i think you have the luxury of
rejecting religion if you're in a
culture which kind of
holds it up but if you're in a culture
that has nothing
that if you're in a culture that has
replaced any sense of the divine
any sense of the sacred with basically
consumerism and individualism then
rejecting religion is suddenly not a fun
piece of rebellion anymore you know it's
like oh [ __ ] i think i've just realized
what that thing was for that we
destroyed
yeah well it's funny because the atheist
promised us
a replacement right they promised us
some some call great cultural
replacement for
the christian story and these these
great acts of participation in this but
that's not what we got what we got is
porn and fast food
like we didn't get because we didn't get
you know a great
start we don't get star trek yeah we
don't get star trek like
this wonderful rational culture of
people who uh
who uh explore with christian virtues
the the galaxy it's like that's not
what's going on
we're getting something much much darker
and much uh
much stranger um well the other thing is
that liberalism doesn't seem to work
without christianity either
yeah i think that's the big story of the
moment that liberalism was the thing
that was supposed to replace
christianity
but as you say and you know tom holland
was very good on this in his book
dominion he was he was he did a very
good exploration of how
liberalism is basically a reboot of
christianity and it works
when you have a society that still
broadly has christian values
but if they've gone you could abide by
liberalism because there's no reason
anyone would believe this stuff because
we suddenly realize
that we're all creating our own values
and there's absolutely no reason we
should all agree with each other and so
there's no center
you know and any society with no center
is not a society and i've seen you you
know
you've talked about that at length i
know but this is um this is where we are
yeah so people are starting to look
around and say well [ __ ] what was at the
center what's going on here there's
suddenly there's a whirling chaos what
have we what have we missed out on
yeah exactly and the desire to to
replace
that there's a there is a desire to
replace it with this
this kind of new woke uh culture um but
it's a it's a dangerous game because it
has a it has a
very powerful scapegoat mechanism that
is not
that doesn't have a solution to it and
so and so people
who are kind of going down that road
will find themselves
they're going to find themselves like
puritans flogging themselves
uh constantly like this kind of
self-deprecation and this
like you that you see these um these uh
struggle sessions like chinese struggle
sessions that you see
uh people are kind of posting about them
because they're noticing that this is
where we're going in terms of a culture
uh and so i it's one
it's what's strange is to realize all of
a sudden that
we're on the edge of culture it's like
i'm noticing like i'm seeing
the type of person that i would that i
would have recognized before
as being the the punks or the these kind
of edge of culture people who can see
where it's going
and are making the the first first
adopters i guess they call them
um that i'm seeing i'm noticing that
they're they're becoming christians
because
or becoming at least more traditional
christians uh liturgical christians
because liturgy
they intuitively understand that there's
something about the world which is
magical
and that there has to be a ritual form
to it there has to be something
you know there has to be this form that
is binding reality together
sometimes it's not it's not explicitly
understood it's sometimes more intuitive
um and then they can see they can see a
liturgical life and
ritual life as part of that so i don't
know if that's something that you
thought about yourself
yeah no a lot actually i mean that's the
other thing i discovered with orthodoxy
is that the liturgy is so powerful
the central ritual is so powerful and
again western christianity didn't have
any rituals in it
or at least it does obviously but not
not that i'd ever seen
as being very significant because the
reformation
changes the role of a church from being
a
a center for ritual to being a sort of
um
center for moral teaching you know you
take out the ritual i mean you still
probably do the eucharist and stuff but
it's a bit
it's a bit by the by really what you're
getting is a lecture
and that's what i always thought
christianity was that it's a lecturer
who tells you what jesus wants you to do
yeah but as soon as you experience a
ritual
then you think oh my goodness me this is
what it's supposed to be about god's in
the room you know this is what's
supposed to be happening here
and again a lot of the work i've done
with mythologists and
reading of myths from cultures around
the world a culture can't survive
without central rituals
and they're always rituals which are
designed to take people to the divine in
some way
beyond ourselves um and we haven't got
that and even our christianity hasn't
had that for a long time in protestant
countries anyway
um and so that's a major loss and it's
one of these things that people don't
even know they've lost
yeah you know i grew up with not knowing
i'd lost this it's a bit like
initiation ceremonies that's another
thing traditional cultures have you know
you'd be initiated from
childhood to adulthood in a serious
culture we don't have that and so we're
perpetually in arrested development
you know all the adults are behaving
like children yeah the aspiration of a
75 year old is to still look like a 30
year old that's
you know because we haven't been
initiated but we don't know we're
missing that either
and you know you mentioned that the sort
of work culture thing i often think that
social justice is like you say it's like
it's like the sermon on the mount
but without love or forgiveness or god
so it's like all the stuff that you
actually need
to leaven that strict moral message that
you get from christ is taken out
and once you have once you have a kind
of moral teaching without love
or any higher purpose you have a tyranny
potentially
but at the heart of it is people trying
to make something
that they think they need because they
don't know what they've lost
yeah and it's uh so there's so many lost
people you know we've all been there
floundering about
thinking there's something something is
really missing there's a massive void
here
yeah but we have no idea how to fill it
and i think that's where we are
and but like you say there's that's a
lesson that's given to us
it's probably a lesson we need to learn
so that's
that's probably the question isn't it
how do we learn that lesson then what do
we draw from it
yeah and how can we because i think a
lot of people are going to learn that
lesson one way or another
you know one of the things we saw in
2020 is a return
of a liturgical action um
you know all the the george floyd
protests the fact that they were
worldwide which is just i mean it's just
insane to think that something like that
caused such a worldwide worldwide
phenomena
but it was really because it was a
religious action you know it was based
on a
on a on a sacrifice which was experiment
which was experienced
as a catharsis by people and you know
this kind of flowing out of religious
feeling and then going out into the
street and processing and chanting and
and kneeling and doing all these uh
these religious gestures and so
it's coming back religion is coming back
there's nothing we can do to stop it
right now
all the all the new atheists they
they're wrong they're wrong about how
reality works
and uh it's playing out and the question
is how is it going to play out because
the sacred has a very the sacred or the
desire for the sacred has a
very dark tendency uh you know and if
you read
i was really i've been talking about the
backing for some reason many times
recently but
you know if you you think of the this
kind of uh
this image of the sacred out of control
which you see in
in the bakke where there's this ripping
apart right the sparagmos of the
of the the of the people this is
something which is right on our horizon
if if there isn't
if there isn't this balance which christ
brought because that aspect of the
sacred is there in the christian ritual
as well you know the communion is
scandalous communion has something
of the human sacrifice in it but it's
taken
up into something more right it's taken
up it's not
let out into its extreme where it
becomes a form of
uh of uh of insane scapegoating or this
kind of
destruction of uh you know this ripping
a part of the king or whatever it is
that
goes on in in these in this religious
tendency we have
it's brought into something higher um
yeah i mean i think religious you know
we all know what religious fanaticism
looks like it's like a dark tendency and
all of us like you say i think
i think in watching in other real films
recently
you said religion is inevitable and i
thought that was that really stuck with
me because i thought yeah that's exactly
right religion is inevitable
so it can take any number of shapes and
some of those shapes could be hideous
right you could be the aztecs cutting
the hearts out of children and throwing
them down pyramids
um or you can indeed be you know
christians burning witches
so there's any number of shapes that
that fanaticism can take
and if it isn't tempered by the fact
that you're supposed to carry a cross
and if it isn't tempered by the fact
that you have to love your enemies even
when they hate you
right you're so you are mandated to love
the people you hate
basically and you'd better make an
effort to do that
because you know and you've got to
forgive people 70 times seven times
and all of this stuff which no none of
us wants to do and it's really hard
but that's you know it's got to be a
reason that christ is endlessly telling
us that
and also endlessly telling us how how
problematic wealth is
and you know st paul's great great quote
about how
god uses the meek to humble the strong
you know he uses the weak to teach the
powerful
and the fact that christ spends all his
time with the poor and the meek and the
dirty and all the people who are shunned
he never spends any time with the
powerful at all until right at the end
and then
when pilate asks him what truth is he
won't tell it it just says my kingdom is
not of this world it's got nothing to do
with you you know if you want to know
what truth is you better
take your shoes off and follow me
because i'm not going to explain it to
you here
you know that there's if you don't yeah
if you haven't
leavened it with that sacrifice of
yourself and not other people yeah
that's the key thing you've got to
sacrifice yourself and not the bad guys
out there because we all hate the bad
guys out there and they're never asked
it's always yours that's really that's
the solution that christ offers it seems
to us like a simple solution because
we've been we've had it for 2000 years
we
think it's obvious but it's this is this
was like the key to all of
reality like the key of self-sacrifice
that that christ gave us is
basically the key to reality of how to
temper all the elements to bring them
all together
because there is a there is this there
is this need
for this this perception we have
that something has to be sacrificed and
you know and then if you're able to to
really understand that ultimately that's
you
then then you're able to to fulfill all
the elements of reality uh
into one into one thing but like you
said it's so hard like
who followed like the the thing about
christ is that
it's a it's this interesting situation
where on the one hand his teaching is
impossible
like it's just completely impossible
with the things he says are impossible
and nonetheless they act as the source
of reality you know and then
you could say that we it all flows out
of of of christ and no one really is
able to completely follow what christ
says because it's a
it's it's a it's an impossible standard
uh but it acts as this
barrier that is very as this this ideal
that that is a true ideal that we can
that we can follow and so the
self-sacrifice for some people will
won't be
this ultimate sacrifice but it will
maybe just be like instead of drinking
the money i get from my salary i'm gonna
i'm gonna give it to my kids right i'm
gonna actually buy food for my kids
can be as stupid as small as that but
then it's part of that notion of
self-sacrifice which kind of feeds into
the world and creates
basically everything good about western
society
is based on on that it's based on the
idea that we understand that the things
we have
we need to put them to the service of
others if even if it's as little as that
it still participates in this ultimate
sacrifice which
we should be aiming towards let's say
yeah so everything good about western
society comes from that teaching so if
you take that out
you just get everything that's bad about
western society right you get all the
colonialism and the coca-cola and
and the self-righteousness but you don't
have what's actually at the heart of it
and what i find so
interesting about reading the gospels as
well is how honest they are about the
fact that virtually everybody who's
following christ also just
walks away you know he's they're always
going what are you talking about
they don't understand yeah don't get it
and they were saying well how can anyone
do that you know what do you mean give
all your money away what do you mean
walk away from your parents what are you
talking about
and even at the last supper he says you
know here's my body and here's my blood
like most of them just say oh that's
disgusting and then they all leave
yeah well that scene in the gospel of
john where he's actually in the crowd
and he says
if if those who do not drink my blood i
need my flesh i have no part in the
kingdom
and you you i think i saw a movie
version of it where they actually
portrayed that scene
he's standing in a crowd and he's
telling people that and you think
if i had been there i would have wanted
to stone him too like
would you think he's saying something
completely
this might be guys like there's no limit
to what he's saying
and that's the you know that's that that
is the story but it's if you haven't got
and that that's all obviously also the
reason why in the early centuries people
thought that christianity was so weird
or disgusting you know this god is
ludicrous
what sort of a god gets himself killed
you know the gods are supposed to be
heroes what do you mean this god is a
weak guy from some tiny little town
he gets himself killed for no reason um
you know that's what's what's heroic
about that
but that's the the that turns the world
on its head
that turns everything upside down i mean
firstly god comes to earth walks in
human form and what do we do we kill him
right that's typically human isn't it we
laugh at him we ignore him we don't
believe him and then we kill him
and then we realize afterwards what
we've done but the story is that
everything that you thought was real
it's not real
you know christ says you know you know
what the gentiles do they get power by
lording it over everybody else but we
get power by serving people
and that's just turn that does turn the
old world on its head
yeah it's a radical notion and as you
say all of us regularly daily fail to
obviously actually do it
but even small gestures towards it if
everybody is doing that
and if everybody has that as the sacred
image that's why the cross fascinates me
so much that's the sacred image that's
god dying up there because we killed him
but he chose to do that
because that's that's what we need to do
as well that's the story that's the
whole story there that sacrifice
defeats death and that sacrifice shows
us how to live
so what are you going to do with that
you know exactly
once but it's interesting because once
you pierce like when you start to pierce
the mystery like once you start to
actually have a glimpse of what
christ is doing and seeing why it had
the effect that it did you actually
start to realize that
reality actually works that way that
like the idea that sacrifice was the
core of how the world works it's
something that has been there for
thousands of years it's always been
there like sacrifice has always been
the the source of reality let's say out
of which
communities would flow the altar would
always be the the most sacred space in
the
ancient pagan temples because there was
something understanding about something
and
it's almost like as it was a puzzle
being played out like there was this
puzzle being set in the world
and the and people were getting parts of
it and parts of it parts of it
and then suddenly you see this image of
the sacrifice of of christ as the
self-sacrifice
um and this this idea that christ did it
in submission
to the father but then giving himself to
to those who were his body and you
realize wait a minute
that's how things work like the the
greatest thing you can do
as let's say the elements of a of a
country like if you want a country to
stay united together
you have to sacrifice yourself to the
higher ideals of that country or
else and then you give your strength
your your body your
your you give your strength to those
that are
around you those that are below you and
that's actually how a country works
that if we don't do that then we're not
going to be able to
to be bound together you can imagine
like a father is the same a father
the father has to give himself to the to
that which is holding the family
together
and then give his strength and his and
his actions down to his children
and and to his wife and so it's like
wait a minute
that's actually how reality works like
christ is actually revealing to us a
mystery that has been kind of hidden
from the beginning and has been kind of
the people have been trying to figure
out and trying to
to embody ritually um and then christ
offers you this
this solution and then then we don't
want to do it because it's painful
and it's because it involves denying
yourself i mean that's the message right
if you if you want to follow me
you deny yourself and you pick up your
cross and nobody wants to deny yourself
and
in this culture if it is culture that we
have in the west now
we glorify the self the self is
everything the ego is everything we're
narcissists we want
stuff um if we don't have i mean this is
the whole
the entire capitalist economy is built
on fulfilling the whims of the self
right you have a need
probably one that's created for you by
an advertising company the need is then
met by selling you some crap that will
be thrown into the sea
um and that's the self if you deny
yourself
none of that matters if you deny
yourself you're living a small and
simple and humble life
which is also the solution to this
ecological crisis because if we were
living small and simple and humble and
selfless lives we wouldn't have one
right because any community that
actually does that as you say a
community a country or family they all
work by everybody having to at least to
some degree deny themselves
and also that's how you live well with
the rest of creation you deny yourself
you don't destroy the forest for toilet
roll
because you understand that the forest
is you know has a right to be there too
and you have to live in some harmony
with it for your own sake as well as for
the sake of everything else
so you take what you need but you don't
take any more you know because you're
not
you're not in it for yourself and it's
such it's as you say no
none of us wants to do that but we're
also in a society now which is
predicated on glorifying the self rather
than denying it so it's
harder than it's ever ever been we even
talk about that as
a realistic thing to want to do as soon
as just weird
you know you're a weird marginal figure
if you want to even think about denying
yourself now yeah
but every time you do it and it gets
fascinating because you
you can see the fruits like i keep
joking about that but how 50 years ago
or even in the 60s we couldn't see the
fruits of their the project we couldn't
see it but now we have the fruits
and so you can notice that let's say if
you're a father
and you deny yourself and you give
yourself
to god and then your body and your
strength to your children
and your attention to your children then
you're gonna
actually find yourself because your
family is going to
function and in that self-denial you're
gonna find love and joy
that you didn't think was possible
whereas if you try to just preserve
yourself and you live for your own
passions and your own desires
then you're going to find yourself in a
shattered family in a in a divorce court
you know fighting over the the who gets
the kids
and you end up in this world of absolute
chaos being ripped apart by reality
um and all of this because you all you
wanted to do is hold on to your own
desires and your own
and your own whims so it actually ends
up being it's like it's not just like
deny yourself and you know you know the
whole world's gonna be better it's
actually deny yourself and
your life's gonna be better too like no
joke it's not just
it's uh even if you you enter into
suffering that suffering will bring you
a sense of meaning and purpose and
communion that you didn't have when you
were just thinking about how to get your
get off or to get your own little
pleasure no yeah quite i mean there's
that's
and there's a connection there between
the zen buddhism i used to practice in
christianity because the method you know
the
the the theology isn't the same the the
central claim isn't the same but
actually the
the notion of the necessity of denying
the self and detachment
that that's the way to ease your
suffering is precisely the same actually
you know if you're attached to all of
this stuff you're going to lead yourself
into hell
and you're going to lead the world into
hell as well but as as i say the whole
of the modern economy that we have now
the whole world that we've built in the
west and increasingly elsewhere
it can't allow that worldview to be real
it has to tell us the story that
glorifying ourselves will make us happy
but as you say we've you know the
evidence is in you know it's been a 60
year or 70 year or 100 year trial period
in which we just break everything down
and economically and culturally and
socially we just kind of go for broke
and take what we want
and mysteriously enough it doesn't work
you know there might be a reason why
every society up until this point in
history
had had a kind of a structure and a
sense of the divine and
a need to make sacrifice to others yeah
so we've got a we've kind of got a
painful path back i think and we won't
go back to the same place
but actually the teaching if the
teaching is there and we're following it
it's going to take us
somewhere where we you know we're going
to be presented with we're being
presented with ruins
that's what's happened everything is
being ruined we're changing the climate
we're driving species into extinction
our culture is disintegrating
we'd like you say we've got rates of
suicide and depression that are through
the roof we've got family breakdown
we've got all of this stuff most people
aren't really happy with it
you can get a lot of instant
gratification in absolutely everywhere
you want
but by the time you're 30 that's getting
pretty boring
if not before so what have you got what
have you got and the more people that
can see this
and the more accelerated it gets the
more people are going to realize
that there's there's an eternal truth
that you have to go looking for
and like you say i think a load of
people are i mean they've been doing
that for a long time but i think now
there's
a kind of real acceleration in something
in that
turn back to oh hang on if we look at it
from the right angle
this message was there all along we just
didn't really see it
so then you've got to work out what to
do with that which is kind of what i'm
still doing
probably lifetime's work yeah listen i i
really appreciate our
conversation um and i i appreciate
i appreciate to know that you're on this
this path with with us i would
say when i say us i mean i can really
notice there's this
strange movement about and there's this
this things are moving and strings are
changing
and so uh and so i'm happy to to see you
on the path with
with all of us and i hope to to find
reasons to collaborate
very soon well that would be great i've
appreciated it
yeah and then i'll definitely finish
reading reading your novel and maybe
move on to others and we can have
another discussion which will be
actually more focused on what you've
written so that might be fun as well
well there's a lot of options there yeah
see if you can get to the end of it
first
all right we'll do that all right thanks
for coming along
okay take care